es ist schön dass es anders gekommen es
ist schön dass die ostdeutschen den mut
hatten aber zu sagen wir werden im osten
verhungert das ist einfach lächerlich
das ist bösartig und um 31 jahre ist es
jetzt her dass die friedlichen
demonstrationen in der ddr wirkung
zeigten und die mauer am 9 november 1989
zu fallen begann
ab diesem zeitpunkt dauerte es knapp ein
jahr bis die beiden deutschen staaten
wieder vereinigt waren ein relativ
kurzer zeitraum in dem die emotionen
sich überschlugen
auf der einen seite unbändige freude
über die neue freiheit auf der anderen
seite traf ein unbekanntes phänomen die
ddr-bürger arbeitslosigkeit die
ostdeutschen sind in einer
kommunistischen planwirtschaft erzogen
erworben haben ihren haben ihr leben mit
einer hohen vorausscheid gestaltet das
war einfach nicht mehr gegeben jeder
muss selber seinen weg finden
jeder musste selber gucken wir wieder
neuen verhältnissen klar kommt und diese
selbstständigkeit die fehlte uns da
waren wir unterlegen ganz eindeutig ich
glaube schon dass dieses denken den
ostdeutschen nicht gelegen hat und
dadurch große soziale persönliche
familiäre verwerfungen auch entstanden
sind
peter michael diestel weiß wovon er
redet von märz bis oktober 1990 war er
der letzte innenminister der ddr nach
der wiedervereinigung verließ er aber
die politik und ging wieder seinem beruf
als anwalt nach er betreibt kanzleien in
potsdam berlin und leipzig arbeitet
selbst in zießler da wo er zu hause ist
in dem kleinen dorf in mecklenburg
vorpommern baute er sich einen bauernhof
zu seinem persönlichen domizil aus auch
ein jagdhaus mit unzähligen trophäen ein
überdimensionaler hochsitz und viele
gemälde finden sich dort
und das ist ein bild das hat einen für
die deutsche einheit gemalt 1992
das ist eine population szene auf der
quadriga das ist ja ossi der gerade ein
großes feuerwerk erlebt wenn sie wissen
was ich meine das ist die bundesrepublik
deutschland alt mit den wunderschönen
eiskalten blauen augen wenn der ob sich
seine hose wieder zugemacht und fertig
ist dann pflicht davon da oben runter
ich glaube schon dass der weg auch über
diese treuhand über das treuhandmodell
gut gewesen ist wenn ich das so sage
dann meine ich das immer nicht weil ich
mit dem rohwetter befreundet oder ich
gebe auch den zweiflern recht die dem
prozess anders sehen
im westen sind die gefängnisse
aufgegangen diddy diddy
wirtschaftsverbrecher haben sich
stresemann anzüge gekauft haben sich
weiße hemden angekaufte goldene
krawattennadel sind so treuhand gefahren
und haben dann die unternehmen für 1
euro für zwei euro und so weiter
bekommen
detlev karsten rohwedder war der erste
chef der treuhandanstalt der die aufgabe
hatte die marode wirtschaft der ddr
abzuwickeln
die folge zehntausende menschen wurden
auf die straße gesetzt und hatten keinen
job märz auf ihre wut darüber entlud
sich in neuen montagsdemonstrationen die
erst mit dem mord an roboter endeten ein
verbrechen das bis heute nicht
aufgeklärt ist der streaming dienst
netflix zeigt in seiner ersten deutschen
serie einigkeit und mord und freiheit
mögliche theorien auf
bildet aber auch die stimmung ist die
einwände ja in ostdeutschland herrschte
denn viele menschen hatten das gefühl
nichts mehr wert zu sein
diese zuspitzung dieser subjektiven
entwicklung hat dann zugeben geführt was
wir erlebt haben und was wir was ich
immer wieder als das größte lebensklug
glück der deutschen bezeichnen müsste
nämlich die friedliche wiedervereinigung
ist in zwei etappen einmal sturz der
mauer 1989 und dann die das
zusammenführen dieser beiden
unterschiedlichen deutschen teile das
ist etwas einmaliges das mit großer
emotion mit großem mit großer
herzlichkeit auch mit sehr viel anstand
klugheit zusammengeführt wurde
danach kam die nacht der langen messer
danach kam die kam die zeit der ars kaya
die sich auf die rudimente der
ostdeutschen wirtschaft gestürzt haben
wir haben deutsche erster klasse und wir
haben deutsche zweiter klasse und ihr
interview führen sie mit einem deutschen
aus der zweiten klasse wir sind die
kriegs verlierer die aussies wir haben
für alle das kreuz des kommunismus
tragen müssen und haben es dann mit sehr
viel mut 1989 weggeworfen
am 17 juni 1990 beschloss die
volkskammer der ddr
das gesetz zur privatisierung und
reorganisation des volkseigenen
vermögens das sogenannte treuhand gesetz
in den darauf folgenden jahren gingen 94
der ddr betriebe an westdeutsche oder
internationale investoren nur sechs
prozent verblieben in ostdeutschland
vielen menschen war auch das tempo mit
dem die privatisierung von statten ging
viel zu schnell wenn man einen
krebskranken körper hat und unsere
wirtschaft war krank dann muss man
schnell operieren ist operiert worden
hat furchtbare schmerzen verursacht aber
der patient ist nicht tot der patient
lebt der lebt nicht so stark wie er
hätte leben können aber er lebt er ist
gesund er hat sich vitalisiert und er
ist aufstrebend die wirtschaft im osten
deutschland ist ja auf streben wir haben
kaum arbeitslose ja wenig also wir sind
aus diesem furchtbaren zahlen die sie
genannt haben natürlich raus gekommen
und ich glaube dass diese diese schweren
operation dieses leid war notwendig ist
es besser den körper schnell und zügig
zu operieren und ein etwas tieferen und
größeren schnitt zu machen als das
harmonisch friedlich narkotisiert über
die zeit gehen zu lassen
ich glaube schon dass man diese
enttäuschten menschen diese dieser diese
traurigen gesicht hat diese dunklen
straßen die über 1991 92
durch diese etwas rigorose treu und
politik erleben mussten diese gesichter
gibt es zum glück nicht mehr und es wird
immer dieses beispiel von helmut kohl
zitiert blühende landschaften natürlich
haben wir blühende landschaften von
anfang an hatten wir blühende land es
wurde immer es ging stetig bergauf
man muss die brille putzen und dann
sieht man auch dass es blühende
landschaften gibt wenn ich die brille
wenn die verklebt ist und von
vorurteilen und von auch von dummheit
von jedes muss dann kann man einfach
diese blühen landschaftlich es ist immer
schöner gewohnt man muss nicht die
menschen die uns aus dem westen geholfen
haben hier rausschmeißen
ganz im gegenteil sagt peter michael
diestel was ihm zur wiedervereinigung
noch fehlt
die gleichberechtigung dass der osten
keine außenstelle des westens ist dass
die sachsen über die sachsen entscheiden
die thüringer über die thüringer genauso
wie die bayern über die bayern oder die
hessen über die hessen entscheiden
dies besagt wenn man das normale
versteht dann haben wir die deutsche
einheit erreicht
dazu verweist der letzte
ddr-innenminister auf einen spruch von
bismarck dieses fenster freue ich mich
sehr
das ist eine hinterglasmalerei eine
glasmalerei mit otto von bismarck und
hier oben ist der container mit dem
deutschen wort fantastisch umgehen einer
seiner schönsten sprüche setzen wir
deutschland in den sattel reiten wird es
schon können
das hat dann 1870 zu reis vereinigung
gesagt also bollermann kluger mann und
in meinem schlichten profan jagd aus
passt da gut rein
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren